[Music]
all right g gov
g golf uh
where'd you grew up originally where are
you from chicago you're chicago i
thought you were in dallas
uh both but i was born in dallas and uh
i mean born in chicago and went to
dallas in my
teenage years oh i see
so you you worked in uh chicago and
dallas yeah yeah
and uh
what was your family like your mom and
dad yeah i got a mom and dad
good childhood yeah for the
good part for the early part of life was
real good and then what happened and
then um basically you know my mother got
off into the
the drugs and
um my father was living in l.a
here in l.a
um he was actually a san pedro
uh military police officer there
and uh we're we're in chicago and you
know like i would say mostly uh probably
not the no male figure in the house
you know
what cause how'd you get introduced to
the game
um
i grew up around it i grew up you know
um
i grew up two
two
buildings over from bishop don juan i
grew up around godfather g.o.d
i grew up around a lot of the the old
school
um greats in chicago so as a child you
know um
going to school you had a
you know you start to make your choices
on what you want to be you can either be
the drug dealer the gang banger of the
pimp
um the the drug dealers were
going to jail the gang bangers were
getting killed and the pimps were the
one that you've seen driving the
catalyst year after year right there's a
lot of beautiful women around
yeah the bishop used to cruise up and
down madison avenue in chicago i
remember probably like you do yeah and
uh
he was treated like a
like royalty down there
he is chicago's royalty yeah he is yeah
that's right he's chicago royalty um and
loved by
many people that's what i mean i mean
people would just flock to his cars yeah
just circle him around every time he
pulled over and
you know i think as i remember i think
the first time i saw him he was like
i think he was helping people out
financially right right you know he'd
like he'd peel off some some money to
some of the people that would come up
with the the the legacy of a of a man
like bishop is not really built on too
much of the the money he gave out but it
was the way he treated people um most
people remember the way they were
treated then whether someone gave him a
dollar or 50 cents on the corner
um they remember the treatment you give
them and the treatment that bishop has
given to the city and to the people
um was always um
love and a caring type of mentality you
know and he's always have positive
things to say never
never a negative person so when you you
meet him it's he gives you the positive
sides to look at everything
interesting
did he uh help you with the your
beginnings in the game
um actually i had the um
he had definitely some help he's
definitely been been um he was
definitely when i was in the game
definitely plenty of help um godfather
god um
pretty much older than me and him was
who i was able to get up under um as i
was able to turn of age 18.
and how did you get your first girl
man in chicago
the hood girl
the girl from the hood you know it
wasn't nothing
spectacular about how i got my first
girl was just the hood girl she in there
you know
doing everything with everybody and it
was just like you know putting some some
order around in her thinking process how
old were you
i was 19 19 yeah i was 19. what is it
what does a a young man need to to do
this kind of
work
is is it something you're born with or
is it something you learn
well it's um is it just survival
it's not too much you need as long as
the girl choosing you know what you want
to do yeah i keep hearing that yeah it's
um it's like
you know um you see the difference in
between um 20 20 over 20 years ago and
versus
today when women chose they chose
because it was the way you were dressed
the way you you you moved the way you
talked your financial gains
she had to see something in you to make
her make that move
um if you're
you know what i say if you're convincing
a girl or if you're trying to talk to
her or convince her or whatever
that's not really a real choosing you
know that's more what they call it you
know you're persuading her
you shouldn't have to you should be able
to just stand there
dressed
beautifully and that should be her
choice because she likes the way you
look
you know
so i think um
you know it's all about what she really
wants what she what do she want now she
gets with you and she sees that your
program is
is shaky your program is
is um not fit for her and she decides to
leave that's cool you know that's where
you know the
she should be able to go anytime she
wants to come in
but um i think i think
with me was it was straight chosen it
was nothing because i didn't have any
game to give him
you know i was just i had got the game
but even i had been around god and
bishop and all them my younger years all
my years you know even when i got the
first girl it was like a freezer like
first time getting the ball on the
basketball court to freeze up you know
yeah i've heard that from so many of the
guys i've interviewed that
even phil more slim said he didn't know
this even this game even existed the
girls the girls came to him and said i
want you to
it was like that with me since i was 14
or 15 years old
you know girls were are you a pimp they
were and i didn't know nothing about
pimping until i got with god
you know what i mean
yeah and what is it what kind of girls
and not every girl can do this kind of
work right
i think any girl could but do does any
do they have the mentality every girl
don't have the mentality to do it you
know i think any girl could do it
because i mean they all have sex
so i think it's all about the mentality
of the woman
you know like when you know something so
precious she knows this even as a child
you know she knows not to give it away
you know she was taught to protect it
you know so yeah
these girls are hustlers yeah these
girls are really right right that this
is what they actually want to do you
know i mean if they didn't want to do it
you better believe um they would be over
there baking cookies or on the soccer
field with their child they wouldn't be
nowhere affiliated with this type of
lifestyle if this is something they did
not want but there's many different
types of temps too
yeah
yeah well there's only one kind of pimp
there's different types of people the
way people do things yeah yeah it's
confusing and my viewers like
crucify some of the guys that i
see
they're they're mainly like
hustlers that are gang wrote gang
related yeah yeah well especially in l.a
and uh and that those guys are still
selling women that are prostitutes but
those women are on drugs and they're
right they're they're being forced or
manipulated or
threatened to do this kind of work
you know it's just it's the same way as
yeah it's the same way as any other um
um a lot of your girls are coming to you
asking you to do it yeah a lot of these
guys do it because it's a trend it's a
fad a lot of a lot of guys started
selling drugs because it was cool a lot
of them started pimping because it was
cool
so when you you'll end up with a lot of
guys and that
shouldn't have been in this lifestyle
and because it's trending and because
everyone's doing it and now they want to
do it you have the gang bangers that
come in and they want to get girls but
they have no understanding you know and
it's really not that's not pimping
that's
you know this is why i that's why i have
to use force and drugs yeah i understand
the difference in human trafficking and
pimping i i understand you know it's sad
that they don't understand the
difference between the two but there is
a difference between human trafficking
and pimping
pimping has nothing to do with human
trafficking and human trafficking has
nothing to do with pimping but you do
have a lot of these guys that get girls
hold them against their will beat on
them um you know don't don't take care
of them properly you have that and then
in those type of cases that's where i
think those charges are um
definitely identical you know
identifying fit
but um you know we're going to chicago
and dallas too say it again is that
going on in chicago um as far as the the
guys that are
playing the game in those in that
fashion not really you you really don't
have too many of those guys that play in
the game like that yeah here in la it's
a big deal yeah yeah you know because
they're mixing in the games they're
mixing the gangs involved with it yeah
yeah whereas guys like you and the
bishop and all that are pretty rare out
here right that's like what we see out
here on the west coast is definitely
different from what we see everywhere
else like when you see guys chasing
girls down
down the street and screaming at them
yelling at them and you know and
i mean nine times out of ten you calling
a woman a b word and
i don't think that you're gonna get too
much of her attention
you know and if you do get a woman's
attention like that you know calling her
out a name and yelling at her and
screaming at her but then that should
let you know something about her
mentally too that she's might not she
might not be fit mentally fit for this
lifestyle
you know and you get a lot of that you
get a lot of people that's not mentally
fit and this is where you get the
the misunderstandings you get the
gorilla pimp you know you get all of
these different i like showing the full
range of it yeah but my audience tends
to get very upset at those kind of guys
yeah yeah and i mean believe me and they
confuse the difference between guys like
maybe yourself and
and sharp and things like that and yeah
real real pimps
don't
it's not in alignment with them mentally
there's no way a real pimp can actually
um
look at a guy like and and
even an abuse of you know the rule is
it's a non-contact sport you know but
the non-contact is between you and your
woman
that's where the non-contact you're
supposed to defend her for anything else
you know when you see guys out here just
running a woman down to the ground and
not trying to
become a team
um
is where you see just so much
of the um gorilla and the and the um
what i call um
you can just say the resistance in the
game
you know you know everybody used to be
together one of the
one of the pimps i interviewed in
memphis explained it i think almost
perfectly he says
if you
don't have any game then you have to
resort to to
force intimidation drug manipulation all
that kind of stuff just to get a girl to
do anything you want to do whereas if
you have the style that some of the
other
guys i've interviewed right right have
or maybe you have right then the girls
come to you
and they're looking for you to do this
is understanding the levels of the game
um a lot of these guys want to go from
um selling drugs or working at
mcdonald's straight to being a pimp and
you have to mastermind the macking you
have to mastermind the understanding of
conversation being able to talk to a
woman um if you don't
i mean if
you know you might be a kid that grew up
and you know you you talk back you got
smacked up so you think that this is the
the result of putting your hands on
someone and smacking them up
and in reality that that's not it's it's
but there are there are men young men
that grew up that way and there are
young women that grew up that way and
that's what they relate to and some of
these girls love to be here that's what
i mean that's right that's exactly i'm
not saying that's right exactly what i'm
saying is it exists right it exists
right right and and
when they get hit for the first time
they go they're home yeah right they
think they think that that's working for
love that's love they think that's not
that that's love that's right that's
right and you can tell you can you can
kind of um seat it out of a girl
you know
you know a lot of back talk maybe not
want to listen
and and and those you could tell those
girls want kind of more friction they
want that yeah they look great right
because i mean if you're in a lifestyle
and it's like you know you go if you got
a job you got a job there's no sense of
um bringing in the extra
um curricular uh mad activity and
so you know you do you have girls in the
game that love to be hit and uh but me i
prefer um don't put your hands on them i
mean
you know it's that's the thin line
between um
on domestic violence in the human
trafficking charge you know no
those girls think these guys are their
boyfriends
that's what they all tell me yeah but
you know um i mean all the girls you got
six women with you all of them don't
think that you're their boyfriend
yeah they do yeah all of them they do
and they are they told me that they are
that's your woman yeah and that's why
the cops have and at least in la have a
hard time
uh getting a conviction on these guys i
think because right you talk to the girl
and the girls just say no he's my
boyfriend right right
you can't arrest a girl for having a
boyfriend or a guy from being a girl's
boyfriend and you can't arrest him for
holding her money right right right
right you know he she brings all her
money 100 of it gives it to him right
but she's choosing to do that but that's
real true pimping that's your woman see
that's where it gets blurred yeah that's
your woman that is your woman i know no
but the lines get very blurred because
those guys are probably doing something
that's
it's it's just it's such a confusing
topic right you you feel like maybe
those guys are still holding the girls
against you know hostage or yeah that's
her name right yeah it's it's well me
personally once that girl
if he's letting her out the door to get
money every day she can leave
that
i can guarantee 99 you know and i
understand how um
the police and everybody look at it so
they want the conviction on the pimp
they have to get the conviction yeah the
cops aren't arrested are is interested
in arresting the girls no they want the
pimp they have to arrest the pimp so to
create this story they have to create a
story that's going to sound good in
front of a juror but if we can keep this
same pattern story going then it'll
finally be believable
um when i came in the game you a girl
couldn't dare run that type of lie to a
police officer she would act
did you go to work yesterday yeah
where'd he put you down along here here
here here why didn't you go get help
then
okay you're using us now for some type
of leverage okay but but today these
girls are able to run this type of game
man if they're letting if you're not
being
handcuffed in the basement and
you know um
you guys are running in and out of the
house and you actually have this freedom
to get out and go you have that freedom
you can just go um
it's just today i think um and i think a
lot of what they're doing is working
they're giving the girls the
the understanding that hey look long as
you come out you can say anything we're
gonna ride behind you and we're gonna
charge these guys no matter what
this is what they're doing now there was
a 16 year old girl that i interviewed
recently right and now that that needs
to be in jail yeah right but but she
told me she had a boyfriend but he was a
pimp right
and
i was trying to convince her that you
know she she shouldn't be doing this
she's probably should probably get a
different life yeah and i even gave her
the money to do so right
she's still with him to this day yeah
and and at 16 i think um
you know both of them she gave the money
she gave the money that i gave her to
get out to the pimp and she's still with
him probably out of fear right
but it's not something that
that she had a chance to go she had a
chance yeah but
you know and my a lot of my viewers will
get upset that i didn't step in and do
something but they don't understand i'm
i'm opera i'm one dude i'm a white dude
of the camera trying to fight against
the bloods right the game right which is
a very powerful gang in l.a yeah
one white dude of the camera is not
going to get very far when the girl
won't cooperate
the pimp has a whole army of bloods
behind him
and there's nothing that's going to
happen right right permanent right you
know i might get her out for a week but
that's she has to make the choice to go
ahead and leave she was back the next
day i think yeah with him
with him yeah yeah and probably won't
leave him
no no and and all the other girls that
were with him had black eyes
she didn't but they did that's that's
why you see the the the trickery now
with the charging of because of stuff
like that yeah and it's very hard for
the police because you're gonna blame
the cops for
not arresting a guy whose girl's
boyfriend right right because you can't
you can't but when you you know it's
just um
you know it's it's sad because like i
say you see so much of the the the the
imposters and
the re that's what you see you know you
should never go to jail
true
when you when you play in the game the
true way you should never have to see
the penitentiary behind a girl have you
done time
yeah before money laundering yeah most
of most of the attempts that are real
pimps yeah as as most people like caught
have done some time but they've done it
for things like money money laundering
or yeah things like that not for not for
yeah mines was for money laundering for
uh at a car lot
so um you know we spent a lot of i spent
a lot of money at the car a lot and
and that's how i ended up in the feds
but never for no not not for pimping um
when i was in the game that was just
like almost
impossible i mean you know you have
respectable women you gotta i'm
respectable we care about each other and
we know what our goals were yeah you
know um
that i think they want to wanted to
pretty sure but i wanted to what they
charged me for pimping oh yeah yeah i'm
pretty sure they wanted to know the cops
i'm sure in your city in l.a they all
know yeah
exactly what's going on yes the cops
aren't dumb no no no they're just
they're their hands are tied in terms of
really getting a conviction right right
right well as it should be in some real
pimping yeah yeah if it's real if it's
if it's real relationships and it's a
real it shouldn't be like that it
shouldn't the woman shouldn't
i mean she's she knows she understands
why she's doing it
you know
one of my one of my friends who i've met
in this lifestyle
that i'm not in but i've done so many
interviews now that i almost feel like i
am
explained to me he's not done an
interview in my channel so don't look
for him but but he's a very
knowledgeable pimp right and he said
what what squares don't understand that
this is almost a form of polygamy yeah
polygamy is where you know right uh
men will have multiple wives right right
right and utah yeah
yeah exists in the mormon community
the fundamentalist mormons and uh
it's a it's a thing that squares just
can't
understand they they just will they
don't
understand that it's something that the
women
choose and are okay with and the men
understand and it's almost like
it's almost like a secret society well
it's no different from um i had a really
good video with a really good talk
recently with ron g who's a pimp in uh
rochester right okay
and he explained that he's playing it
beautifully that it's like a secret
society that that most squares will
never understand and you know and i
think they do understand it
i think it's the money that's generated
and the the guys that are behind it it's
mostly your african-american um black
pimps that are behind it yeah i think
that causes a it rubs it just rubs
i don't mean to be a jerk but white
males that can't get a woman right are
very envious of dudes like yourself
right
they just are yeah and it goes to there
and it's like okay these they're black
you know when when blacks were selling
drugs they were giving them 50 years and
100 years of life sentence in federal
prison because they figured out a way to
make money here in this country um it's
the same way even with this game um
i mean um was it
dennis hoffman ran one of the biggest
prostitutions yeah in
uh he was sitting on the the city um
board for um
on the government board in the city
where he got it he ran for mayor in the
government dennis was not an idiot right
he knew he knew how the government
worked
he knew prostitution better than anybody
right right yeah i mean he was pretty
much him you have no idea
and you're right you know and all the
other well he's he called himself that
hugh hefner no uh dennis hoff dennis
yeah
well you know i wouldn't no i wouldn't
say he's a pimp but he ran a hell of a
prostitution ring he sure did yeah he
ran the hell of a prostitution ring you
know did he do i think he had the
concept and mentality of what it takes
to be a pimp no i don't think so i think
you have a more of a great business mind
and you utilize it with women almost
like the way you hefted had a very great
business mind and that's the other
aspect of being in the game do you have
the business mind to orchestrate it into
a business structure to be able to to
get money legally i don't think blacks
just went that
far
you know what i mean to um organize it
more in a legal a legitimate matter or
even try to find a place to pass laws
that make it legal you know it's just
it's like the the crack law no one
wanted to step forward
until 20 30 years and then obama gets in
office and he's creates these crack laws
but at first you know in the 80s no one
would have stood up for it because it
was horrible
and the same thing with the human
trafficking no one's going to stand up
for into 20 30 years down the line and
then people are going to stand up and
these guys are going to get released
early release because you know now it's
not so harsh
when i grew up in the 80s
gays didn't come out in the public it
was like the most harsh thing to do is
to come out and say oh i'm gay i mean
it's 2021 you can't even say
nothing bad about gays on social media
you're gonna get paid the world has
changed right you know so
so we're looking at the evil i'm looking
at the evolving of the way the world
becomes sensitized desensitized
sensitized desensitized now you're
taking out you know the um
african-am
american
history from the texas school system you
know first you guys were sensitive to it
in the 60s and 70s and 80s and 90s but
now you're not desensitized you're more
desensitized to racism in here in
america so now let's pull it out now
so you know i think the world just goes
through this phase to where now
pimps are being more demonized to um
for for the lack of understanding it's
probably the the most extreme point in
history when right now right where pimps
are just demons demons right now they
are they are just evil dudes and this is
the most like you said this is the most
this is as far as the public understands
the public right the public's perception
of a pimp is that they are just evil
dudes that's right period that's right
and a lot of these girls
and some are yeah but but some are not
right because
but what i think a lot of people don't
understand is that the uh culture
the the the the street culture right
that you that you've probably grown up
in right and a lot of the pimps have
grown up and
is a
it's a hustler mentality yes it is that
exists on the street that the pimps and
the girls live in and they've grown up
in and they're not going to change right
but what you guys are doing is maybe a
a flashier more civilized version of
hustling
yeah that's what it's actually it's a
flash he wants to yeah
um it's not the killing you don't have
to worry about the game yeah no one's
getting killed yeah you know you're not
killing anybody right you didn't get
ak-47s uh blazing on the on the tracks
but
i mean you're starting to see it a
little bit more now because of the gangs
becoming involved into the into this
lifestyle yeah and that's the part of
i mean i call them pimps but maybe
they're not but yeah but they are
selling women for
for the
for profit and prostitution
but most of my audience goes oh those
guys aren't pimps but that's what
they're doing so that makes them pimples
yeah
but it's a
the way i see it is is there's a market
for what these with these women are
selling yeah right yeah it's the market
you want more you want to blame the
woman
you want to blame their manager which is
guys like you yeah
do you want to blame the trick which is
their customer right maybe maybe you
should blame the the wife of the trick
this game could be blamed on so many
people right right
and
it definitely can i mean and there's
really no blame to something that people
will no it's just society yeah it's
human nature
you know it's human nature right
but you know we all got like a little
i think everyone has their little faults
something they did wrong here there
but and and i do understand the
lifestyle itself can have a bad taste of
someone that don't understand it but
absolutely that's that's the wisest
thing to do he just said
that's it you know you might not want to
go to the military you might tell your
son no or you you know it's just you got
some people that's gun holes i'm sending
over my kids to the military right you
know it's just the lifestyle some people
just choose and it's yeah and and what
i'm trying to do is just create a little
more understanding of how the world
works right right and doesn't right it
works off of money it's thrived off of a
stride off of off of money
that's i don't think nobody out here
would do the things they do if money did
not was not involved money is king yeah
money is king and if it and i know it
was here you know before money was
created even back in the biblical days
but
it's it's it's the thrive of um the
barter system um you know
we want we want things that we don't
have
you know i think we all just want things
that we just don't have
you know and that's the stressful part
of our living huh
yeah it really is yeah that's really
stressful it's just
you know it's just
there are so many different cultures in
our country
and the african-american community
in the city you grew up in which is
chicago yeah which happens to be the
same
community same city i grew up in oh you
grew up in chicago i'm from chicago okay
yeah okay what's that north west side
what's up oh okay
i'm up here let's give my audience a
really good
uh idea of how different you and i grew
up okay
i didn't come from a wealthy
neighborhood but i'm a white dude right
i'm a white boy i'm a white boy from the
western suburbs and you're a black dude
that grew up on the near west side of
chicago right right
what madison avenue
you and i couldn't have grown up more
differently why right
i mean maybe no you you said you had a
pretty good childhood right yeah i had a
pretty good job yeah but but most guys
like yourself
didn't right yeah yeah most of them did
most of your friends probably growing up
had dads that were in prison yeah pretty
much most of them
are already you know dead or something
yeah and they had moms that were yeah on
drugs right
yeah
yeah so and i didn't but
it's just i almost think it's a societal
thing that is hard for many to
understand
yeah
most of the most of the country doesn't
understand
how
few opportunities guys like yourself
maybe had
maybe not you you specifically right
right i'm being i'm being i'm
generalizing but most
of the united states doesn't understand
how
few opportunities
black males
had
as young men
and how here's here's maybe the most
important part they didn't understand
how
few good role models they had
that's crazy because that's what i was
getting ready to say
it's basically the the your surroundings
yeah i mean the new question
of my barrage of questions that i ask
over and over again of the
uh
prostitutes i've been interviewing is
how how many
good examples of loving relationships
did you have as a child
you know what their answer is
none
none none they
they never saw a loving relationship in
their lives no
not even out of their own parents no not
from themselves not from their
grandparents nowhere
so what do you expect them to do america
yeah
what do you expect these women to do
yeah and then what do you expect the
young men to do right
right they've never
seen
a loving relationship
no
no
you did right yeah i had i have you
you're an exception yeah i had
grandparents um
i had my mother and they wasn't together
my father but my mother was definitely
loving as a matter of fact when i um
because my mother was in the street life
too she was well known in chicago
um you know with bishop don juan and all
of
them
maybe your life wasn't as as
yeah as different as as most of the
other
it was a little different but it's like
you get some people went to the streets
to get the game and then some people got
it at the breakfast table right at home
so um you know it was more um but we we
it was always love you know we was well
taken care of there was five of us we i
have a twin brother too named president
we were well taken care of i mean my
mother would you know she would do
whatever it took to make sure what are
your siblings
um brother named president yeah yeah
your name is governor governor yeah
what's your other brother um famous
yeah yeah
these are giving names no no no no no no
okay no but the um street giving names
that we've been going by for over 25
years okay
yeah but um yeah i had a very good
um
i couldn't i couldn't complain i had
good parents you know i mean you know
even though my father didn't live with
us i had pretty much the support from
either side but i you know at a young
age we were you know going in and out of
juvenile homes and
you know pretty much pretty much the you
know real bad kids you know what i mean
and
so you know transferring over to this
game it was more like you know um
or my mother seen it
coming up the way we came up when she
seen it and she seemed she she looked at
me she said oh so this is what you want
to do
and she seen all the girls in the car
and i was like yeah
she was like well i'm gonna tell you one
thing you know
you treat them right love them and care
about them
and they're gonna do the same for you
and i just looked at her because that
was the first time i heard that after
being in the game um almost three years
and when i looked at her
she was like i'm telling you treat them
right and love them
and that's been my that's always been my
um
that's been my number one um
rule in the game
is if i'm gonna deal with her i'm gonna
i'm gonna have to love her and if i
can't love her then
i don't wanna be around her
well
because you know
love is what builds hate tears down so
even in this game you have to be able to
um
gas true love for these girls you can't
it's not no big eyes and little yous and
it's um it's no different from a couple
from you and your wife being married you
and these girls that y'all together
and um you want the relationship to last
forever you know you're not looking at
the relationship
you know they say cop and blow i believe
cop and lock you know
and the only way you're gonna do that is
through true love and not the the
beating the the yelling the screaming
and all that
you won't have a successful relationship
and no relationship can it be successful
in that type of matter no relationship
at all
you know so my mother she when she gave
me that that was enough for me to take
it
take me off
and ensure
beautiful women real ones around me
because you ain't a pimp without a
prostitute
you are not a pen without a prostitute
awesome all right giga thank you so much
for a very interesting talk appreciate
it all right thank you very much all
right
you